Washington State man is crediting an
apple watch with saving his father's
life after a bike accident this is a
remarkable story the man says he was
waiting to meet his dad in a state park
when he received a text message reading
detected a hard fall along with his
father's location he received the
message because his dad had listed him
as an emergency contact
his father had flipped his bike hit his
head and was knocked out right so the
Apple watch called 9-1-1 with the
location the son said his dad is a
little sore but he's doing great he's
also encouraging everyone who owns an
Apple watch to make sure the hard fall
detection feature is turned on I got a
demo I'll have it
I got a demo of this watch last week and
they told me about this and I was like
man that's never gonna work are you
calling them today I got a fine back
future now I I've been an analogue guy
my whole life but now I'm thinking I
need to get one of these watches that's
amazing great that the other thing
that's great is about the heart that's
why that's why I like it so much you can
do your heart beatin can tell you if
it's out of whack for me yep you know if
you get an email you know don't don't
throw your watch in anger because you
know the paramedics might be coming yeah
that's well don't throw your watching
angry at anybody Tony come on very cool
it's an amazing feature all right thanks
Vlad you can watch Vlad on our 24-hour
streaming service cbsn find it on CBS
news.com or on the CBS News app